[Music]
on this tuesday night recommendation
reversal the oxford astrazeneca vaccine
now deems safe and effective for
canadians
over 65. we try to monitor the evidence
plus the latest on the evidence about
blood clots and why doctors say you
shouldn't worry dreading a third wave
what's driving up cases in some
provinces
healing the healers psychologists need
psychologists too
the pandemic's toll on mental health
professionals
and the frenzy about non-fungible tokens
i could just do it off my phone or on my
computer the trend in digital
collectibles
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with news about the oxford
astrazeneca vaccine and a major change
to the advice on who can get it in
canada
the national advisory committee on
immunization now says the astrazeneca
vaccine is safe and effective for use in
people
65 years and older it says there's
enough
real world evidence to show it protects
seniors from severe disease and
hospitalization
that reverses an earlier recommendation
made because people older than 65 had
not been included in the original
clinical trials
at the same time though more european
countries have suspended use of the
astrazeneca vaccine in all age groups
sweden and latvia are the latest to
suspend the shot after reports
a small number of recipients developed
blood clots
the european medicines agency says there
is no indication
the shot caused the blood clots it is
carrying out rigorous analysis
of the reports and will deliver
conclusions it says on thursday
currently we are still firmly convinced
that the benefits of the astrophysenica
vaccine
outweigh the risk of these side effects
reports of blood clots after the
astrazeneca shot are very rare
according to the vaccine developer there
have been 37 reports of clots among the
more than
17 million people who have been
vaccinated in the eu
and britain it is important to note too
none of the vaccine batches under
investigation in europe
have been shipped to canada expanding
who can get the astrazeneca vaccine here
is causing the provinces to rethink
their vaccine rollout
michael couture has our top story
tonight
i think that people have to realize that
it's not that we're flip-flopping it's
just that we try to monitor the evidence
the head of the national advisory
committee on immunization might have
sounded a little defensive while trying
to explain how the guidance changed
in a matter of weeks nasi never said the
oxford astrazeneca vaccine was bad for
canadians aged 65 and older
there just wasn't enough data to prove
it was good
and dr caroline quash 10 used a colorful
analogy to describe the enormous task of
approving a vaccine
ideally you know we would do one
recommendation with all the data in hand
but
that's impossible so that's why you know
you start with one thing and you
start chewing that elephant slide slice
by slice
this is a real one right here that
explanation was tough to digest for
ontario premier doug ford
he's promising people already booked for
the shot through the province's
pharmacies and primary care settings
that they won't lose their spot but he
says the new guidelines throw a wrench
into the province's immunization plans
they're changing and moving the goal
post i can't begin to tell you
the logistics behind it it just
messes everything up to be very frank
with you ontario and nova scotia are now
both reviewing the new nasty
recommendations
i'm a little upset with nasty as well
this epidemiologist says the committee
should have seen the real world data on
the vaccine
sooner quebec did that and already
started using the vaccine
in that age group but there is concern
the mixed messages around
the shot erodes faith in the process
unfortunately we can't wait
two years until all the answers are in
before saying
this is our best estimate of how these
vaccines work and where it should work
you got to do it now to save to save
civilization
and that's only possible with proper
communication and some education
which lead to buy-in from the population
mike lacouter global news ottawa
there is a lot to digest about vaccines
and information changes as more people
get them
based on the evidence from europe now
public health doctors like bc's dr henry
say there is not cause for concern
we have to remember as well that over 17
million doses of astrazeneca
have been given and so far 37
cases of these blood clots in different
ways
have been detected this is lower than we
might see even in the general population
without vaccination
there is lots to take in about this to
add more clarity dr suman chakrabarti
an infectious diseases physician joins
me doctor people sometimes
get blood clots i had deep veins
thrombosis for example had nothing to do
with any vaccine
based on the evidence so far should
canadians be worried
about the astrazeneca vaccine based on
what we know so far
in our trials and also what's seen in
real world experience in the uk
there's no signal that there's any
increased risk of clots and it's
important to watch for this uh you know
in the post-marketing analysis but right
now there's no evidence for this so i
think that right we have this vaccine
that's quite safe
and effective and i urge canadians to
get it we are still in the midst of a
pandemic
half the new cases in ontario for
example are now the more transmissible
variants of concern
can we afford to hesitate about getting
vaccinated
it's a good point and you know people
have a lot of questions i think it's
important to answer them and alleviate
fears but yes
vaccination is our ticket out of the
pandemic and it's important to try to
get as much
widespread vaccination as possible i
want people to be able to make an
informed decision and that's what our
job
is right now to help with that but
overall we have now four
choices that are very very good and safe
and i would urge canadians to get
whichever one is offered to you and we
can get out of this
this outbreak as soon as possible the
risk analysis risk benefit analysis
what are the risks of not getting
vaccinated right now especially for
people over the age of 65
yeah we do know that as the older you
are the higher risk you are of getting
severe disease of covet
hospitalization and of course death and
you know the thing about
covid it's something that can uh you
know affect you
in a way that you might not even expect
so i think it's important that with
vaccination
we prevent all that we prevent death we
prevent morbidity and that's i think the
biggest thing we want for all of our
population protect everyone
and really kind of get the key to
exiting the pandemic
and making this all a memory behind us
that would be nice
dr chakrabarty thank you so much thanks
for having me take care the provinces
are
progressing and administering vaccines
though it is still slow going across the
country today more than 104
000 doses were given more than 2.6
million people in canada have now
received at least one dose that
works out to roughly seven percent of
the population
ontario science advisors are warning a
third wave has taken hold in that
province driven
by the more contagious variants of
concern and there are troubling signs
the variants are spreading fast across
parts of western canada too
heather yurix west looks at where this
is leading and what needs to be done now
to slow it down drive through
immunization clinics in regina
saskatchewan are up and running
but it will take more than vaccine to
get this city out of a very troubling
spot
my concerns are many actually grave in
fact
of the nearly 500 active cases in regina
right now
nearly half are either confirmed or
presumptive cases of new
variants we had to look at a
sharp uh immediate and a short lockdown
you know of of a circuit breaker type
uh you know uh to keep the you know to
keep this
variance from really getting away from
us
if we would just let our guards down
completely
then we're really talking again about
thousands of cases per day
and it could be considerably worse than
what we've seen during the second wave
we need to be aware of that
the virus is spreading most quickly in
ontario where variants of concern
now account for half of all new cases
and are driving new growth
but in the west the situation is
escalating too
both bc and alberta have seen case
numbers rise since mid-february
while manitoba has seen its test
positivity number grow day over day
since the beginning of march though so
far officials in both alberta and bc
don't believe numbers are increasing
quickly enough to warrant
serious concern right now we are still
in a very small percentage of our cases
that are variants of
concern but that's simply not the case
right now in ontario
it's really hard to know exactly how
this is going to play out but
it's pretty clear there's been a rise in
cases over the last week and that's more
than a blip that's a real deal
and with vaccine campaigns months away
from hitting that critical mass needed
to control
the virus tighter health restrictions
may once again need to come
into play a tough reminder that while we
are close to the end
the government 19 pandemic is just not
over yet
heather yorks west global news calgary
moderna has begun testing its vaccine in
children between the ages of 6 months
and 12 years
the company intends to enroll about 6
700 children in canada and the u.s
in the study it will assess the safety
and efficacy of two doses given
28 days apart and will include a year of
follow-up
in december moderna began testing its
vaccine in 12 to 18 year olds
moderner is approved for use in canada
for people 18 and older experts don't
expect it will be approved for use in
children
for some time the past year has taken a
toll on the mental health of many
canadians whether they realize it or not
and the people we turn to psychologists
counselors and therapists are also
bearing a heavy load guiding people
through these troubled times
ross lord looks at how the people caring
for our mental health
are coping with their own ever since the
pandemic started
nurses and other health care workers
have been rightly singled out for their
courage and
endurance but another group on the front
lines has been largely ignored
mental health professionals i would say
there's a five-fold
increase in people seeking help and
people are entirely correct to be
seeking help in these circumstances
dr simon sherry says turning away people
who need help in nova scotia's
underfunded mental health system
has left him stressed out you're helping
people with the problem while also
suffering the ill effects
of the problem at the same time a
predicament they don't normally discuss
publicly some pandemic adjustments
they've made with clients are easier to
share than others
like switching to virtual sessions they
go to their
car and go out into the middle of an
empty parking lot because that's the
only place they can get
privacy or in people who have
large families young kids um i've had
sessions take place within
sheds walk-in closets
the downside for everyone is inescapable
in a survey posted by statistics canada
in february
70 of health care workers reported their
mental health was either
somewhat worse now or much worse now
than before the pandemic
when asked how stressful most days are
for them now more than half replied
quite a bit stressful or extremely
stressful
like other studies of its kind it did
not include mental health professionals
who are also struggling with compassion
fatigue and the threat of burnout
you can't provide support and care to
others unless you're
in a centered space and able to provide
that to yourself
psychologists need psychologists too
sherry says in addition to monthly peer
support meetings and mountain biking
he turns to his family for support one
of my key coping tools was to go home
and walk around the living room with my
baby
every night it was good to hold that
little guy
and to feel close and comfortable with
him coping
while hoping the pandemic ends soon ross
lord
global news halifax a senior military
officer and veteran of the war in
afghanistan is leaving the canadian
armed forces
because of what she calls the failure of
its leaders to deal with sexual
misconduct
in a letter to her commanding officers
lieutenant colonel eleanor taylor
requested her release from the military
as soon as possible
she says she is sickened by ongoing
investigations of sexual misconduct
among our key leaders
she adds she is not surprised by what's
happening and says she is certain the
scope of the problem has yet to be
exposed in alberta a 19 year old has
been charged with murder after the
stabbing of a fellow student
at a high school yesterday morning the
student who died is 17 year old jennifer
winkler
police say she was stabbed multiple
times in a classroom at christ the king
catholic high school in leduc
she was airlifted to a hospital in
edmonton where she later died
hours later the suspect a student at the
same school was arrested
dylan thomas pountny is charged with
first degree murder
investigators say the two knew each
other but haven't specified how
when it happened the school was put into
lockdown and students are struggling to
understand what happened
classes have been canceled and trauma
and grief counselors have been brought
in
to help them cope a canadian actor makes
history coming up what elliot page
just did as he reflects on his life's
journey plus
an update on prince philip
halifax born actor elliot page has made
history as the first openly transgender
man to be featured on the cover of time
magazine
it is his first interview since he went
public in december with his gender
identity in transition
34 year old describes it as a feeling of
true excitement and deep gratitude to
have made it
to this point in my life but that it's
also mixed with a lot of fear and
anxiety
he says past awards shows and red carpet
appearances were especially
challenging telling time magazine i just
never recognized myself
for a long time i could not even look at
a photo of myself
he says my privilege has allowed me to
have resources to get through
and to be where i am today i want to use
that privilege and platform to help
in the ways i can prince charles says
he's thrilled his father prince philip
is back home
after a month in hospital the duke of
edinburgh who turns 100 in june was
admitted for an infection and then
transferred to a second hospital for a
heart procedure prince philip is now
back home at windsor castle with his
wife the queen and is said to be in good
spirits
families facing fewer options for help
ahead battling rare diseases during the
pandemic
everyone has been affected in some way
by the pandemic people who are being
treated for rare sometimes
fatal diseases have suffered more
hardship than most
including children tonight karen
lieberman has some of their stories
three-year-old joseph cortner pushes his
big sister on the backyard swings
it's bittersweet because he's taking
like a big brother role even though he's
a little brother
five-year-old claire is one of around 15
children
in canada fighting a rare deadly disease
batten disease cln2 is a
regressive neurological disorder that is
almost like a combination of many other
diseases
they slowly lose the ability to
walk they slowly lose the ability to
talk they'll get dementia
claire is not alone in her battle it may
not look like it
but joseph has the disease too for the
gortnars the covid19 pandemic has not
impacted the children's regular enzyme
replacement therapy
but they are feeling the effects of the
virus in other ways
how do you do pt virtual how do you do
ot virtual
you can't the canadian organization for
rare disorders is pushing ottawa to move
ahead with a rare disease strategy
promised in the 2019 budget one billion
dollars for two years beginning in 2022
with dedicated annual funding to follow
last march when we finally got to the
government to say okay we can begin
consultations almost a week later is
when covet happened
one in 12 canadians is living with a
rare disease
that's nearly three million people most
are children what a book like michael
piravillakis who has an
ultra rare neurodegenerative disease
called [ __ ] paraplegia 50. michael is
one of 61 in the world and the only one
in canada there is no cure
but there is hope that gene therapy will
be able to halt
and potentially reverse the effects of
the disease for us to manufacture and to
get it to the fda
and through the regulatory process it
takes a lot of time a lot of money
time is not on michael's side spg 50
will begin to rob him of all of his
functions
and the pandemic has severely slowed the
ability
to fundraise we have to cancel our golf
tournament we have the cancer gala
what hasn't changed for these families
over the last year
is the need to take precautions to live
in their own bubble
and as canadians line up for a covid
vaccine
they pray for cure karen lieberman
global news toronto
let's get digital next decoding nfts the
virtual craze with some really big price
tags
okay this next story requires you to pay
attention because it is the next big
thing and it's a bit hard to grasp
it's about non-fungible tokens or nfts
[Music]
this techno song is an example elon musk
produced it it's about
nfts and it's being sold as an nft he's
already had bids of over a million
dollars apparently
non-fungible tokens are digital tokens
that enable true
ownership of any kind of digital asset
so a song artwork or a moment in sports
you can't touch it but you can own it
told you you had to pay attention
our senior business correspondent ann
gaviola has more details
this digital collage created by an
artist who goes by the name beeple sold
last week for 70 million dollars it was
sold as an
nft and on saturday the nft of the
internet mean grumpy cat sold for more
than 83
000 u.s so what exactly is an nft
it stands for non-fungible token
fungible is something that can be
swapped for something of equal value
something that's non-fungible is unique
not easily exchangeable for something of
that exact
value nfts only exist online they come
with proof of ownership
stamped into a blockchain a digital
ledger that's like a receipt
issued by the content creator proving
that you own the rights to that video
clip
artwork article or even a tweet most of
these digital rights contracts live on
the ethereum blockchain and must be
purchased in its cryptocurrency ether
the world's
second biggest cryptocurrency next to
bitcoin nfts have been around for years
but interest in them has picked up in
2020 they became a market worth a
quarter million dollars
one of the latest nft crazes is nba top
shots
digital videos and art the modern day
equivalent of trading cards
so a moment that i would love to collect
is like the kawaii leonard game seven
shot as raptors fans
we all remember that game seven shot
it's been stitched into our brains
sheedle jaitley spent about five hundred
dollars on nba top shots
he says they're now worth more than five
thousand dollars i feel like a kid again
i don't necessarily have to go to the
store and buy all these baseball cards
and hockey cards like i did when i was a
child
it's great to see i could just do it off
my phone or on my computer alex tapscott
wrote about nfts in his book blockchain
revolution
he says there's irrational exuberance at
play but that doesn't mean the
technology isn't here to stay
we're talking about art which is
something that you know appeals to
people on an emotional level maybe they
see it as an investment something that
they'll be able to
resell at a price later on financial
experts say stimulus money pandemic
savings and extra time spent online have
all fed into the nft surge
but this extra bandwidth for digital
assets may also be limited
a good general rule of thumb is not to
put your money into anything that you
don't understand
so if nfts have piqued your interest
make sure you do your homework
and understand the risk inherent in
investing in something
whose value is determined by an online
community whose interest and attention
could shift ann gaviola global news
toronto
well that's good advice and that is
global national for this tuesday i'm
donna friesen tonight's your canada is
beautiful
lake louise alberta thanks for watching
robin gill will be at the anchor desk
for the next couple of days i'll be back
saturday for the new reality
take care of yourselves bye-bye